[Música]
lo que están viendo en estos momentos es
una multitud que en estado de alta
excitación está tardando de ir de una
zona de riesgo o una zona segura la zona
de riesgos es el túnel por ahí vienen
toros porque estos San Fermín Pamplona
año 2013 y lo que ocurre es que las
puertas se empiezan a cerrar un poco
antes y se produce esa
situación de un tapón humano que impide
los que están en la zona de riesgo
llegar a la zona segura y además los
somete a los que están ahí caídos en una
altas presiones la mayoría de los
heridos vienen de esa región esto suele
ocurrir con resultados mucho más
neumáticos por ejemplo año 2968 partido
Boca-River en la cancha de River y se
ocurre la famosa de tarjeta de la puerta
70 y pico de muertos en el año 2003 por
ejemplo en Road Island
discoteca se prende fuego el escenario
donde grupo llamado white quería este
usar fuegos artificiales ciento y pico
de muertos ciento y pico de heridos
y se abre recientemente en otro contexto
en una festividad religiosa en el norte
de Israel monte Merón
100000 personas empiezan a ser la
evacuación
por un este pasillo que tenía 5 m de
ancho y 10 m de largo que terminaba en
escalera se produce una aglomeración
caídas y nuevamente 40 muertos cientos
de heridos
este tema atrajo mi atención
ese pero soy Néstor físico nuclear no
pega muchas veces me dedicado a cosas
que no pega más por ejemplo
tuvimos una charla
respecto de vacunar o no a mí nietita
estudiar en la acción de los grupos
antivacunas fondo de un mayor matemático
de la propagación de opiniones en una
sociedad y estudie cómo se oponía la
propaganda de los antivacunas con la
propaganda que eventualmente podría ser
el Estado termino en un paper que lo
publique y vacunamos a mi nieta
muy bien pero ahora lo que
cómo estudiar científicamente el
problema de las multitudes en estado de
alta tensión o hasta pánico lo que
necesitemos formar un modelo matemático
que extraiga las características
fundamentales del fenómeno que queremos
estudiar
lo que usamos en su moderno que está
conformado por
cilindros personas
no completamente rígidos
y cuando esté está en el seno de una
multitud no demasiado densa no se van
avanzando sobre los otros y es como si
hubiese una fuerza de repulsión con los
demás y tampoco se rozan sobre las
paredes a no ser que los obliguen pero
en principio no lo hacen repulsión con
la pared
más o menos normal pero ahora le vamos a
agregar el ingrediente
básico fundamental que le da un sabor a
este asunto estos cilindros personas
tienen voluntad Irene alguna dirección a
cierta velocidad
y la alcanzarla en un cierto tiempo
muy bien
esto que seas ese modelo matemático le
implementamos una computadora y
estudiamos qué es lo que ocurre en
termino de esa velocidad deseo entonces
en nada virtualmente todo construido una
una este
sala de 20 * 20 m en la cual coloco 225
personas una única salida esa sala que
tiene un ancho de 4 personas y resulta
que estos indoor personas en un dado
momentos intenta imperiosa necesidad de
evacuar ese lugar porque perciben riesgo
para su vida
y el grado de tensión de estas personas
está dado por la velocidad con la que
quieren salir
exploramos este este problema durante
cierto tiempo largo tiempo muchas
simulaciones numéricas y demás y
empezaron a surgir resultados
inesperados
sorprendentes por ejemplo
y yo quería evacuar y celular
y consideramos la posibilidad de que se
apaguen las luces y que la visibilidad
fuese nada más de 2 m
resultado aquí la evacuación se podía
ser más rápido que la gente iba a correr
contra la pared y va a seguir hasta
encontrar la salida
pero si además
y colocamos en la pared virtualmente
siempre flechas luminosas que le
indicaban para dónde ir pero en vez de
hacerlo de modo que recorres en la
distancia más corta la salida nos
hacíamos circular siempre en el mismo
sentido Eva con más rápida
y finalmente el resultado más
espectacular que se llama el faster is
slower effects más rápido es más lento y
esto que estamos viendo acá he visto
desde arriba de los cilindros personas
que están saliendo a esa velocidad es
tenemos un metro por segundo 2 metros
por segundo y 5 metros por segundo
resulta que como ustedes están viendo
los que están evacuando más rápido son
los que estamos viendo en la velocidad
intermedia
y los otros dos están saliendo han sido
elegidos hábilmente la velocidad es para
que lo haga más o menos a la misma
velocidad
pero ahora te voy a pedir que se fije en
el modo en que están saliendo estos
cilindros personas del recinto
si se fijan en la velocidad más lenta lo
que vienes que subir sus clubs en más o
menos continuamente te está saliendo
gente mientras que las que quieren ir
más rápido están saliendo a borbotones
y esos fotones se generan porque si
ustedes
se están formando ciertas estructuras
como arcos que retienen a los demás
obviamente es todo llamamos estructuras
bloqueantes
nuestro primer trabajo lo terminamos el
30 de diciembre por la tarde del año
mandamos el paper o publicar 80 en
facebook República porque así funciona
eso
y nos vamos a nuestras casas porque
empiezan las vacaciones de verano
press and HF Chrome
más allá de que pase un momento
complicado
mi hijo mío no parecía
después tome consciencia de que estos
190 muertes que ocurrieron en Cromañon
correspondían a lo que yo he estado
estudiando
entonces obviamente eso me marco para
siempre eso lo incorpore como línea de
investigación
y este me dije dos objetivos uno que
ella en conocer bien el proceso
encontrar algún tipo de solución
y otro que Dios se lo cuento después tú
se lo digamos a estudiar este problema
mucho
perfeccionando en modelo confrontando lo
con este información no experimental
sino filmaciones de tragedia que habían
ocurrido
y resulta que
nuestro camino de experimentación
empezamos a investigar que pasaba se
colocaba un obstáculo delante de la
puerta
y resultó que colocándolo vilmente
no grabamos mejorar la evacuación
colocando un obstáculo suena extraño
pero pero si era
exploramos columnas y
demás
eso quedo ahí seguimos investigando
tenemos investigando son nuestros laburo
y resulta que
en un dado momento eso llegamos al
concepto del vestíbulo
qué es el vestíbulo
vestíbulo es
poner delante de la puerta de salida una
estructura
pared pero le podemos agregar puertas
qué determina una región y ahora vamos a
ver una simulación en lo cual confronto
de un lado una salida normal que se
investigo y del otro lado con el
vestíbulo que son esas dos está
representado por esas dos rayas rojas
son las paredes primero primer de taxi
STS fijan con vestíbulo se sale mucho
más rápido así estamos sacando a la
gente de la zona de riesgo o
eventualmente está prendiendo fuego le
permitimos que vaya a la zona segura
pero lo vamos a ver este vamos a darle
tiempo a que termine la lenta
y al verla de nuevo le pido que se fije
en los colores
el marrón es alta densidad alta presión
y la azul lo contraria o sea que no solo
logramos que se evacúe
esté más rápidamente sino que sea más
seguro porque las altas presiones son
las que provocaron en el caso de San
Fermín el que le mostré las heridas y
demás
o sea que como confidente thank hemos el
primer objetivo que me había planteado
después Cromagnon es tenemos una forma
de salir más segura
más rápida y una condición más que los
caminantes en los peatones los humanos
no tiene que ser entrenados de un modo
especial para evitar el drama y la
tragedia sino que simplemente tiene que
salir como siempre
pero través del vestíbulo
la otra idea que me había empezado a
surgir a partir de Cromañon y que le
dije que venía al final viene ahora y es
que habiendo encontrado una da solución
al problema lo que tenemos que conseguir
es que las autoridades correspondientes
la implementen porque se demuestra que
las muertes eran necesarias
evitables
y acá tenemos las llaves para impedir
que ocurran más tragedias muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]